it seems like a lot of people have a
particular experience while getting into
the EDH format and that experience goes
something like this they find a
commander and a deck they really gel
with like it speaks to them on some deep
level and then they Embark upon a great
optimization Quest pouring increasing
amounts of time and money into making
the deck as good as it possibly can be I
went through this process about 10 years
ago with my first commander deck and I
understand this impulse you've got your
baby and you want it to fly this process
can work to some extent especially if
you have big piles of money to throw at
upgrading a deck and I encourage
everybody to put effort into making
their decks as enjoyable as possible for
themselves which may mean power upgrades
that said there are actually some pretty
compelling reasons not to upgrade a deck
further once it plays smoothly at a
healthy middling power level so in this
video I'm going to go through each of
these reasons using one of my midow
decks to exemplify each of them and then
I'll be talking about what decks are the
best candidates for an upgrade
the first reason not to upgrade a deck
is that some decks have natural
bottlenecks in their functionality that
makes it difficult to give them a
cohesive upgade and the most common
bottlenecks here are being vulnerable to
a particular type of hate or having a
game plan that is fundamentally
difficult to speed up if your deck
relies heavily on the board presence of
a commander that's more than three Mana
your opponents only need to hit out your
command Zone a couple times early in
order to shut you down if your deck
heavily relies on building up a
graveyard over the course of several
turns a single piece of graveyard hate
can totally blow you out and card
quality improvements alone won't
generally change this fact if your deck
heavily uses board wipes to maintain
control over the game or something like
go for that matter you'll struggle
against Decks that don't rely on combat
damage or which are more explosive which
get more common at higher Powers
ultimately trying to improve a deck with
a bottleneck like this will generally
lead to some very good games with the
deck but much worse consistency with the
deck getting dragged down to the dirt by
bottlenecking factors a decent portion
of the time this is the reason I don't
upgrade my Sherm slide deck there are
ways to make it much more efficient at
generating value and controlling the
game but the deck has several
vulnerabilities its astral slides
getting hated out its artifacts getting
wiped Andor its graveyard getting exiled
the deck can play through these things
happening a little bit but decks
generally run much more of these things
at higher powers and if it encounters
too much of these sorts of hate the deck
will fall flat on its face regardless of
card quality upgrades an extension of
this problem is what I'll call the cheap
deck this is a deck that works pretty
well at low budgets but is very
logarithmic in terms of how it
translates additional budget to
additional power it gets rapidly more
expensive to improve it past a certain
power level the best example of this I
can think of is feather it's a commander
that has a decently beefy Voltron game
plan if you build your deck specifically
around it which usually means running a
lot of 1 to two Mana instance and
sorceries that Target creatures along
with some cards that work well with
these sorts of spells it's hard to end
up with a feather deck that's bad but
it's also hard to build a feather deck
that's really good one Mana instance and
sorceries that Target creatures are
cheap so you're already running the best
ones meaning that the only option for
trying to improve the deck is cutting
some of these for generic value cards in
the colors and the weakening of the
feather game plan that this results in
will negate some of that increase in
power this reason is also why I don't
try to improve my Maria deck one to two
Mana equipments are the decks bread and
butter and there just aren't that many
options in this category of card outside
of the dirt cheap ones I'm already
running and ones I consider
prohibitively expensive the other reason
not to increase the power level of a
deck is if you simply don't enjoy the
power level you end up at if you're
playing in a group of Beatdown decks and
everybody is relentlessly tuning the
effectiveness of their Beatdown that
might feel okay in that context but your
deck might end up on the power level of
a deck that consistently combos off on
turn five or Voltron kills you on turn
four or forcefully suppresses your deck
into the dirt with an unending stream of
hate and even if you're still pulling
off your fair share of wins against
these sorts of decks as a player you'll
need to ask yourself the question of if
that's the sort of MTG you want to be
playing you also might need to slip
combos into your deck instead of winning
in ways that play more to your deck
strengths which a lot of players might
not find to be a satisfying way to go
with their deck this reason is why I
leave my gissa deck at a middling power
level it's a deck that wants to build up
resources and then play a bunch of big
stuff winning through gaining board
superiority and beating down its
opponents rather than playing some sort
of explosive card like torment of
Hailfire or tutoring up a combo I play
the deck to do beefy battle cruiser
things and become the big bad of the
table not to pull off a sneaky win when
my opponents aren't looking okay so the
point I'm trying to make here is that
some decks are less ideal candidates for
upgrading past a certain point you know
you should maybe call them good enough
and I do fully believe in this idea but
I think it's also useful to consider the
terms here what do we mean by upgrading
a deck
I'd say there are two main factors that
determine a deck's power level card
quality how good the cards are and
cohesion how well the cards are put
together I'd say we as magic players
tend to overwhelmingly focus on the
first one when we think about a deck's
power level particularly when it comes
to the question of upgrading and I
actually think this makes perfect sense
to do when you're asking whether or not
you should improve your Deck card
quality you're talking about an
unambiguous exchange of resources money
for power level whereas cohesion is a
much more challenging factor to modulate
particularly for a deck that's already
fully built with that in mind I'd like
to offer an additional framework you can
think of upgrading your deck's card
quality as a tool for obtaining the
deck's desired power level if you have a
fundamentally janky premise for a deck
that you want to end up decently
powerful running good card quality can
accomplish that goal to some extent as
long as you tread carefully around
potential bottlenecks if you have a
fundamentally powerful deck concept and
you want to play in a a group of more
middling power decks you can restrict
your card Choice by budget or theme or
some other Factor but to this you might
ask what does it mean for a deck concept
to be fundamentally powerful or
fundamentally weak this takes me back to
the core question of this video the
question of when a deck should be
upgraded with better card quality I
mentioned feather as an example of a
deck that generally performs solidly on
a low budget but which could be
difficult and cost inefficient to
improve past that point as a point of
contract F I want to talk about a
different popular Commander that like
feather tends to convert a specific card
type into resources for a fast game plan
yuo the tiger Shadow yuo decks span a
range of power levels and contain a lot
of variety in sub themes and card
choices but all of them share a
fundamental game plan play evasive
creatures Andor ninjas and utilize these
cards with uo to whittle down your
opponents through a mixture of combat
damage and yuo triggers generating card
advantage in the process uo not doesn't
have the same ceiling as feather because
she's fundamentally a faster more
resilient and just simpler card
Commander Ninjutsu at two Mana
immediately puts her head and shoulders
above feather in terms of raw power and
instead of being fiddly and requiring
constant upkeep or extra steps to reach
her full power she converts lowcost
ninjas and evasive creatures into very
fundamental resources of the game card
advantage and life loss for opponents
and can do so with minimal Mana
investment Dex can vary in how many
ninjas they run and what sorts of
evasive creatures they play but these
cards are basically guaranteed to be
effective due to the speed resilience
and simplicity of Yuro and as long as
the deck is above a certain minimum
number of these supporting creatures
these cards combined with uo to form a
very powerful core to the deck it's this
strong core for generating generic
resources that makes a deck especially
upgradeable there's a good amount of
diversity in what a successful uo deck
can look like and there are lots of
peacemeal card quality upgrades and
packages that can be added to modulate
the deck to whatever power level the uo
player wants to be playing at I think
it's worth clarifying here that there's
nothing wrong with commanders that are
better suited to midow nor is a
commander like Yuro or corval that
inherently pushes a higher power
necessarily more interesting or more
worthwhile there are also the players
who like the challenge of trying to
boost a commander or theme that isn't
inherently high power up to that point
and that can be a fun process I
personally like the challenge of
building powerful decks on a low budget
as it forces you to put a lot of effort
into the cohesion of a deck since the
card quality is naturally going to be a
bit lacking at the end of the day I just
want people to know what they're getting
into when they decide to pour time and
money into a deck if you have a limit on
how much you want to spend on decks it's
valuable to know when you're dealing
with a commander who will naturally take
more money to boost from a mid- power
deck to a high power deck and as stated
earlier this will fundamentally come
down to how how powerful a deck's core
resource generating and game-winning
pieces are and even if budget isn't a
concern it's worth keeping an eye on a
deck weak points and making sure that
they aren't going to be exacerbated by
playing against more powerful decks I
feel like there's a culture among a lot
of EDH players of higher powered decks
being considered cooler or more
interesting which leads to this sort of
rat race of chasing generic Staples and
applying formulaic rules to every deck
to bump up its power level and I don't
want to tell anybody not to improve a
deck they want to improve but I just
want to tell you right now that if you
have a midow deck you really like you
don't necessarily need to change it if
you want a higher power deck you can
pick out a couple things you like from
an existing deck you enjoy such as a
card or a theme and then build a new
more powerful home for it this also goes
for putting Pet cards in decks but
that's a topic for another
day